on se veut permettre aux arts martiaux
chinois de se démocratiser
vous êtes en terre étrangère logiciel
croyez moi si vous viviez ici vous
comprendriez dans le quartier chinois de
san francisco nos studios de beaune fo
ne devrait accepter que les élèves
chinois
comme je voulais déjà dit
vous ne pouvez pas comprendre m hitman
parce que ce pays
est le plus grand et le plus puissant du
monde
ça rentre dans vos têtes oui c'est
clairement de la provocation et c'est
tout c'est ça votre couple chinois
que s'est il passé
melexis
face à l'injustice
je ne peux pas rien
aucune règle
pour ce pas jusqu'au 15 août et une fin
de tournoi
pourquoi
g
l'essai
donc vous êtes enseignant russie
j'enseigne kung fu chinois et c était la
gymnastique
oh
hier oui en quelque sorte